oui
[Musique]
raconte moi quand lui confie de jeunes à
dire quand j'étais petit j'étais comme
d'oise étaient très curieux aux curieux
quelle grande armoire je voudrais bien
savoir ce qu'il ya dedans
j'ai fermé à clé titus je t'en prie ne
touche pas à chaque armoire
pourquoi d'informer bien géré mais je
n'ai pas trouvé la clé ont la clé il n'y
a plus de clés elle est perdue on ne l'a
jamais retrouvée tout ça bien mystérieux
que c'est sûr que cette armoire contient
trop plein de croissance j'aimerais bien
ouvrir garde sûrement car sauve la balle
jaune et beaucoup de noix
et me poserai les commandes pour bouffer
par mois sans clé est le bolide a rien à
faire
il importe elle comme outil venir est
bien temps louvre temps moi très bien
accueilli il est parti j'avais peur que
titus dhabi mme sept à pouvoir en
essayant de l'ouvrir il n'est pas là je
suis tranquille
ep elle est bien fermé
voilà avec the beauty on finira bien par
l'ouvrir
bon réveillon la barre de fer hongrois
lafarge a perdu la borne beau-père l
armoire nouveau permet ben effrayant
nous bien faire des coups on voir un nom
de café et laval tous fermés allons
voyons avec la si elle est bien aiguisé
je vais faire un grand trou à l'antenne
ne pourrait pas c'est super dur à
rattraper
émond et offrit aux fêtards moi il me
restait plus envie de l'ouvrir sans
marteau a l'air solide moi j'avais tapé
tapé gozé par marc capitte nu et voilà
mon dernier où tu café et cette armoire
toujours fermé c'est l'heure de la plaie
alors qu'y puis-je tus et du collage ou
du bricolage nanogrammes heures à revoir
son fou tu réfléchis un peu le marché
s'est donc installé une clé il n'a pas
la tête comme moi mais ils se saoulent
de klein d'un contre sur moi je suis un
véritable porte klein un haka but
atteint pas le voile la robella dont
bobek sauver la france formaient adjabi
attendant il faut elle n'a alors d'autre
bois des précisions presse us quelques
lettres faut-il il nous faut la quête de
cette armoire voilà voilà voilà je vous
l'avais dit plus tôt cela montre aussi
je m'en sers jade main tebi que bhl je
suis sûr qu'elle est là c'est la bonne
tu donnes deux tours et l'armoire son au
revoir le droit yaka bâton
[Musique]
tout y est valeo mer où on vient de le
voir qu'il ya là dedans
[Musique]
elle est vide
absolument vide vous m'en donnez tout le
monde pour rien pour mia et après après
tête une autre est points